hello everyone and welcome to the final
game of the 2018 women's US Chess
Championship but we have a game between
the NASA Phi kids ax and anyway now okay
some pronounce it nah see some pronounce
it Nadia Yassir pronounces it nauseous
so I don't know who to believe but I'm
sure you will correct me in the comments
as usual she already won one United
States Championship title for women in
2016 so this is her well third attempt
last year she was unsuccessful in doing
so and she already holds two titles as
the World Youth Chess Champion four
girls and four times European Youth
Chess Champion four girls in her age
category so quite a quite a lot of
titles for her and she faces anyway now
now this isn't the first video I'm doing
on anyone I'm sure you all remember that
video I made it was I believe in the
2017 Youth Chess Championship where any
one a tournament would nine and nine and
a half out of ten and she she won two
hundred and eighteen rating points in
one tournament that was insane I will
put a link to that video if you want to
check it out in the description below
where I say something more about Annie
so how does this work I really thought
that anyone would win the United States
so when women's championship as she was
constantly in first place constantly in
first place would a full point lead and
then she lost her last game which which
put her in a tie with NASA Paquita
and then they had to go to a to a
tie-break and even in the tie breaks any
Wang won her first game against naazy
and it was a it was I mean it was like
how do you come back from this and then
the next game naazy one with the black
pieces and they had to go into an
Armageddon game so this time it was a
bit different
you always know that in the Armageddon
White has like either five minutes and
but gets six minutes but black can also
black can also draw black doesn't have
to win but here it was a bit different
here instead of just just the time
difference there was also a two-second
increment so it was even how how to put
it it was even easier for black the
whole whole draw with the wood the
increment
so let's just see the game in the in the
tiebreaks NASA got the white pieces and
so she has to win this game if if any
draws the game or wins then then she is
the United States Women's Champion so
let's see the game and it's a very
interesting because it's until one point
it's the same game that was played in
their previous game in the Rapids in the
tiebreaks but you'll see what happens
then so we have Knight to f3 starting
with a reti opening east six g3 and
Knight to f6 Bishop to G to b5 now so we
have the Kings Indian attack on the
board
castles Bishop to e7 d3 and c5 Knight B
to d2 Knight to c6 e for b6 preparing to
the world the light square Bishop e5 now
nice to e7 now both Knights are
attacking the e5 pawn you have to defend
this rook e1 Queen to c7 adding more
pressure to d5 pawn Queen e2 defending
and the bishop to b7 now and here nasi
goes for c4 so this is completely the
same like their previous game they
played in the tiebreaks d4 and here we
have nice to f1 night the nice to e4
does seem like an excellent square for
the knight but you can never get your
knight here because you constantly have
to defend e5 pawn so here we have knife
to f1 h6 and h4 by nasi here any plate
queenside castle and this is completely
the same like in their previous game and
here is here is the difference but first
I did prepare some photos for this move
here is a photo of the two of them this
was after the original championship so
before the tiebreaks even started and
here we have let me just check yeah here
we have it this is a grandmaster
gurgi kashish really and it was after
the first two games so in the tiebreaks
in in in the in the previous game as he
played h5 here and after h5 rook rook d2
f8 was played by any a3 and then any got
some nice counter play with the g5 and
after that game like I said
master yogi catches really he told an
Aussie that she should have gone for a
different idea here and it's he isn't
her coach or anything he just he just a
fan and he wanted to help out
so here his suggestion was a night 1 to
H 2 so this was played in the game no
longer going for the immediate H 5 and
in the previous game white really
weakened the position by playing pawn to
g4 but in this game night will come to
g4 and white will have a much better
game so g5 and it goes for the same idea
as in the previous game she wants to
open up the Kings side and now h5
locking the Kings side and in the
previous game and as it was kind of for
a kind of no she wasn't forced but she
decided to block the position here with
g4 this game the night is coming to g4
as was the suggestion of Grandmaster
Akashi is really so rook D to f8 and now
Knight comes to g4 King to b8 we have
Bishop to d2 and now f5 e captures on f6
on pass on Knight captures and now
Knight comes to f5 90 G to f5 g4 but now
g4 is is not really a threat because now
Knight captures and c6 would check
Bishop captures and now the other night
comes to comes to e5 we have a Bishop
captures on g2 King captures and Queen
to b7 this comes with check and King to
g1 and here it's very difficult now to
find the move for black when a Z is
completely controlling D file and Knight
the g6 is a terrible threat that will
win the exchange and there really isn't
a good move here there is a there is a
kind of a strong engine line that
suggests Bishop to d6 and after you
allow nice to g6 attacking the rooks
than e5 you give up you give you give up
a rook for a night but you close down
the e-file and you pretend like white
didn't really achieve anything so that's
that's one way to go about it
any and it doesn't play this she goes
rook to e8 and now comes Knight to g6
attacking the bishop opening up the
attack from the Queen to the pawn and
here rooked
rock to h7 as the rook was attacked on a
shaped Queen captures on e6 and now
Knight captures on h5 there really isn't
a good move here there's simply too much
pressure
d there's a triple attack on the e7
bishop the bishop can't move because
this rook is under attack ideas like
Queen captures on f6 will even be on the
board so it's it I mean both of them are
low on time but any is any is even more
in time trouble so he or she goes nice
captures on h5 Queen captures on g4 and
although this isn't the best move
probably best is simply check the King
and pick up the night here it's a free
piece but okay she goes in knife captor
Sun g4 as this is also winning black
really doesn't have a move here so
Knight back to f6 was played you don't
really you you can't really go for some
Knight captures and g3 ideas maybe
opening up the King and then maybe going
for some sort of an attack because this
comes with check and it's a pretty
pretty forced variation that exchanges
everything Knight captures on e7 rook
captures or captures rook captures and
now Quinjet check will simply force a
trade of Queens and you are you're up up
up a piece and the upper pawn so this
would be completely winning so after
this Queen to g4 Knight to f6 was played
Queen to f4 check a king a8 and now
Knight captures on e7 also possible here
instead of capturing the bishop was
capturing the night one of the ideas we
talked about after Bishop captures rook
captures on the 8 with check you have to
block with the Queen Queen b8 and now
rook captures and again you are you're
up a whole piece your Europe a knight
so after King to 8th and 9th captors on
e7
rook to f7 or or you capture the night
and then Queen Kiara's on f7 oh it's all
the same route to f7 now comes Knight to
f5 rook captures rook captures now nasi
is already up a piece Luke to f8 we have
rook to e7
attacking the Queen Queen to c6 the
Queen doesn't really have a good square
to go to you can't really allow check on
f3 Queen captures on h6
rope to c8 and
Roop to f7 and here any display any
display Queen to f3 but even before she
played that she lost on time and we
don't even have a photo of this moment
there you have it
zero point zero zero on a nice clock and
there's a queen on f3 so this mode was
played but but only after she ran out of
time so yeah all of these all of these
photos are from chest coms articles so I
will put the article in the description
below you can read some more about both
of them about this championship and for
for the end of this video I have
prepared for you the final standings of
the United States 2018 US Championship
for women as you can see an Aussie
pickets in 1st place $25,000 prize then
anyway then arena crush then Una's a ton
skin
Jennifer you and so on and so on last
year's the last year's winner Sabina
voice or only got as you can see 7th
place here so not not not the greatest
attempt at defending the title but you
know you it's it you can never you can
never predict these things so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Daniel Martinec
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully I will be
starting another series soon and you
will get that poll today thank you all